hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
vision welt sondern ich jetzt diese
kategorie oder diesem kanal
es bleibt zwar auf dem gleichen kanal
aber so nenne ich das jetzt immer wenig
kochrezepte einstellen und heute möchte
ich euch ein ganz leckeres rezept
vorstellen und zwar sich so gerne nudeln
schmecken und ursprünglich war das mal
so ein typisches rezept von mir
das macht man mit yoga und das werde ich
auch noch zeigen
und zwar ist es so eine abwandlung von
den türkischen maultaschen von nannte
aber heute habe ich ein deutsches rezept
für euch und zwar sind es gefüllte
nudeln schmecken mit einem chris
nudelteig und mit einer leckeren gemüse
soße und einem joghurt und der
unterschied zwischen den türkischen und
den deutschen nudeln schmecken ist dass
diese deutschen model schnecken in der
pfanne gebraten werden und die
türkischen im ofen und hier könnt ihr
ganz schön sehen wie lecker das aussieht
und wenn ihr wissen wollt wie man diese
leckeren nudeln schmecken macht dann
bleibt jetzt tragen ich verrate euch
jetzt einmal die zutaten für den teig
braucht ihr 150 gramm weizen kreis kleve
hartweizengrieß 250 gramm mehl etwas
olivenöl etwa drei esslöffel einen
teelöffel salz 3 eier und etwas 7
esslöffel wasser wobei es auf die eier
größe darauf ankommt also je größer die
eier sind umso weniger wasser brauchen
wir können die zutaten jetzt natürlich
mit der hand verkneten oder so wie ich
in der küchenmaschine das ist einfach
viel bequemer einfach alle zutaten rein
hier noch die drei esslöffel olivenöl
und die drei eier und jetzt gebe ich
erstmal drei esslöffel wasser mit dazu
und wettern einfach schauen wie der teig
wird wenn er zu trocken ist gebe ich
noch wasser dazu und der teig sollen
schöner fester tag seien eben wie so ein
ganz normaler nudelteig
ich habe jetzt insgesamt sechs esslöffel
wasser rein gegeben in den teig und muss
sagen es war fast schon zu viel
aber so ist er wirklich noch großer tag
also da darf auf keinen fall zu weich
werden
ihr kennt das ja auch von nudelteig dass
da er fester ist als weich
jetzt freue mich ihn einfach zu einer
kugel zusammen und gebe ihnen der kleine
schlüssel und so lasse ich ihnen jetzt
eine halbe stunde lang ruhen
in der zwischenzeit bereits jetzt schon
mal die füllung vor
und dafür brauche ich 500 gramm
hackfleisch ich habe jetzt hier in de
hackfleisch zweier ich habe hier drei
zwiebeln ihr könnt auch zwei große
nehmen aber da ich jetzt nur die
mittlere größe haben nämlich 3 2
esslöffel semmel mail das mache ich
übrigens immer selbst ausgetrocknet und
brot ich habe hier einen bund petersilie
bereits fein gehackt habe hier zwei
knoblauchzehen oder eben zweieinhalb
wenn die größere knoblauchzehen habt
reicht auch eine aber ich finde so in
der menge ist es optimal
ein teelöffel salz und hier habe ich
noch eine muskatnuss in meiner reibe
drin und etwas pfeffer die zwiebeln und
den knoblauch werde ich jetzt fein
hacken
jetzt kommen alle zutaten in einer
schüssel und werden darf verrührt jetzt
noch mit der muskatnuss würzen und
ordentlich mit pfeffer würzen und wer
möchte gibt jetzt hier noch ein paar
chiliflocken mit dazu
jetzt muss der teig ausgerollt werden
und das klappt finde ich am besten auf
silikon matte da gebe ich jetzt dennoch
etwas mehl drauf weil ich gar nicht weiß
ob datei klebt oder nicht aber
eigentlich dürfte er nicht kleben
ja das gut und ich werde ihn jetzt so
groß aus rollen wie die matte
das sind etwa 40 x 35 cm und das geht am
besten auch mit einem silikon aus rom
starb da bleibt nämlich wirklich nichts
dran hängen
und wenn jetzt es dann soweit habt kommt
da jetzt diese fleischmasse drauf und
die verteile ich jetzt einfach mit den
händen und theoretisch könnte man da
auch etwas gemüse mit einarbeiten aber
das sollte man vielleicht vorher etwas
garen damit es dann auch durch ist wenn
gebraten wird hier am rand lasse ich
jetzt einen zentimeter frei
und ihr seht sich ab jetzt über einen
rang freigelassen
hier etwas mehr und jetzt werde ich das
ganze auf rollen können sie jetzt
natürlich von dieser seite aufrollen
dann habe ich dickere mönchen und
dickere schnecken aber ich wette es von
der kurzen seite her aufrollen einmal so
und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch hier
den breiteren rand damit hier später
eben die rolle zusammenklebt und jetzt
beginnt ihr hier unten das schön drauf
zu legen
und dann schneidet die rolle mit einem
scharfen messer in etwa 2 cm breite
stückchen
und dann könnt ihr die schnecken auf
einen teller geben da könnte es auch
nochmal schön rund formen
denn durch das schneiden verformen sie
sicher so ein bisschen
für die sauce braucht ihr etwas olivenöl
dann etwas suppengemüse also karotten
hier etwas sellerie etwas lauch und
petersilie
dann braucht ihr zwei kleine tomaten
oder eine große 200 milliliter wasser
und einen gemüse brühwürfel etwas
tomatenmark etwa einen esslöffel etwa
zwei esslöffel schmand und etwas pfeffer
den lauch welt jetzt einmal halbieren
und jetzt kann ich ihn unter fließendem
wasser schön auswaschen also dass jeder
ganze sand weg geht
das gemüse wird jetzt grob zerkleinert
das müsste jetzt auch nicht ganz genau
machen weil es später sowieso genug
püriert wird
das gebe ich jetzt schon mal in einen
topf
und wenn mein mann nicht so geizig werbe
damit größere messer kaufen meine sind
nämlich irgendwie verschwunden und den
rest mache ich jetzt einfach in meinem
zerkleinerer ich hab da auch noch einen
anderen zerkleinerer den finde ich
persönlich etwas besser aber da ich
gerade in der spülmaschine und diese
schlucken gemüse gibt es überall in
jedem supermarkt zu kaufen so als beutel
oder in so einem kleinen kistchen da
müsste einfach nach suppengemüse gucken
immer das gleiche drin
und jetzt gebe ich da noch die karotten
mitteilen wo ich hätte mir größere topf
nehmen könne
ich nehme jetzt auch nicht alle also
dass ich mir ein bisschen zu viel und
jetzt wird das mit einem esslöffel öl
etwas angeschwitzt es einfach fünf
minuten lang dünsten
wenn es dann so ein bisschen gedünstet
ist kommt ein esslöffel tomatenmark mit
option
das lasse auch kurz ein bisschen
anschwitzen
und hier habe ich bereits die tomaten
zerkleinert die wirtschaft auch mit rein
dann kommt hier das wasser riss und ich
gleich gemüsebrühe würfe und dann darf
das so ein bisschen vor sich hin köcheln
so etwa zehn minuten und in der zeit
werde ich jetzt die nudel schnecken
anbraten und ich benutze immer die
gemüsebrühe würfe von alnatura da sind
nämlich keine geschmacksverstärker drin
und auch keine hefe das nämlich auch
geschmacksverstärker das wissen die
meisten nicht und außerdem sprühten frei
und zu dem thema glutamat mache ich mal
ein verbraucher video hier habe ich
jetzt in meiner pfanne etwas
butterschmalz erhitzt und wenn ihr kein
butterschmalz habt und mit butter
arbeitet müsst ihr auf jeden fall etwas
öl mit dazu geben damit die butter nicht
verbrennt also butterschmalz verbrennt
nicht in der pfanne luther verbrennt
deswegen da in schuss öl mit rein und da
gebe ich jetzt die note schnecken rein
und wenn sie bei mittlerer hitze von
jeder seite etwa fünf minuten anbraten
ich mache das ganze jetzt in zwei
pfannen als ihnen eine nicht passen
sieht es also jetzt gerade bei mir aus
ich habe es die ganze portion nudeln
schmecken gemacht und brate jetzt alle
weise heute tritt sind und alles
ziemlich hunger haben
hier kostet die soße vor sich hin und in
der zeit wie das jetzt fertig wird werde
ich jetzt noch meinen joghurt dip machen
ich habe es hier etwa 400 gramm joghurt
das ist ein zehnprozentiger dann nehme
ich immer so einen türkischen joghurt
und nehmen jetzt einfach zwei
knoblauchzehen fein würfeln und in den
joghurt geben
ich nehme doch nur eine weil ihr
ziemlich groß ist und das reicht auf
jeden fall
das wird jetzt noch gewürzt mit etwa
einem halben teelöffel salz und etwas
pfeffer den mal ich immer frisch weil
ich finde das so der pfeffer am besten
schmeckt dann wird es noch schön glatt
gerührt und das war es dann auch schon
wenn die nudeln schmecken dann soweit
sind können sie gewendet werden
das werde auch die richtig tolle farbe
die soße wird jetzt noch püriert
und jetzt auch bei mir muss da auf jeden
fall noch wasser mit rein
und wenn ihr gezeigt dass diese menge
viel zu viel ist für euch dann nimm dir
einfach den fertigen nudeln schmecken
die rohen nudel schnecken und können sie
ganz toll einfrieren dazu gibt das sie
einfach in eine flache form und gibt ein
bisschen backpapier drüber und dann
können das auch übereinander stapeln und
wenn ihr sie daneben zubereiten wollte
holte sie aus dem gefrierfach haus und
müsst ihr einfach nur raten also das ist
wirklich ein ganz tolles rezept da gibt
es keine ausreden mit fertig essen weil
das kann man wirklich sehr schnell
vorbereiten
ihr habt jetzt bereits in diesem und
auch immer im letzten video gesehen dass
ich so ein paar neue tools in meiner
küche habe da die ich gerade ausprobiere
und da möchte ich ganz gern den markt
grüßen damit die alle zur verfügung
gestellt hat zum ausprobieren
die geräte sind wirklich alle top und
ich finde wir sollten uns bald mal mehr
zusammenschließen und darüber sprechen
also die sachen sind wirklich super
und wenn euch das rezept gefallen hat
würde ich mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr
mal auf meinem blog vorbei schaut da
habe ich die genauen mengenangaben noch
mal aufgelistet
und natürlich freue ich mich darüber wir
nehmen den kommentar da last und mir
eine bewertung geht dann bekomme ich
nämlich auch ein feedback dafür wie ihr
das video und video wie ihr das rezept
findet und dann wünsche ich euch auf
jeden fall einen ganz schönen tag schon
mal einen guten appetit und alles andere
gibt es bei www.welt.de und ich sag dann
einfach mal tschüss
ich wollte eigentlich dass die familie
heute beim backen hilft was ich auf der
couch eingeschlafen war das ist banking
keine ahnung